Und wie alt sind Sie?
42 Jahre alt.
Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin geboren am 19. Jallor 1982.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin ungefähr 1,79 m groß.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege ca. 76 Kilogramm.
Und wie heißt Ihre Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausarztin?
Es ist Herr Schmitz.
Okay, Herr Brunze, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 29 Jahre alt.
29 Jahre alt.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,78 m groß.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
82 Kilogramm.
Wie heißt Ihre Hausarzt oder Hausarztin?
Ich habe aktuell keinen Hausarzt.
Ich bin umgezogen.
Und ich war jetzt nicht krank gewesen.
Okay, das ist wichtig, aber Sie müssen so ein Hausarzt anbinden.
Ja, aber...
Ich bin nicht krank, wenn da wohl nichts wahrzugehen.
Okay.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Student.
Student.
Was sind Sie genau geboren?
Könnten Sie mir sagen?
Ich bin am 17.07.1995 geworden.
1900?
1995.
Okay, Herr Brunze.
Was ist Ihre Hauptbeschwester?
Was fühlten Sie so uns?
Ja, ich habe heute mit meinen Freunden.
Herr Schmidt, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 62 Jahre alt.
62.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 12. März 1962.
12. März 1962.
60.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,75 m groß.
75.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin ungefähr 90 kg.
Genau.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Pfeiffer?
Ich bin 36 Jahre alt.
36 Jahre alt.
Okay, wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 15.09.1989.
Okay, 14.09.1989.
Genau.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,84 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie so seit?
So 92 kg.
92 kg.
Okay.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Münder?
Ich bin noch 69.
69.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 18.09.1955.
195.
Okay.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Münder?
Ich bin so 1,74 m.
70.
1,74 m.
Okay, Herr Schuldiger.
Wie viel wiegen Sie aktuelle?
Ungefähr 83, 84 kg.
Danke.
Wie alt sind Sie und wann sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin 69 Jahre und bin geboren am 19.06.1956.
Wie groß sind Sie und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,68 m.
Wie geht es zur Zeit so 79 kg.
Knapp unter 80 Jahren.
Herr Bergmann.
Wie alt sind Sie und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin demnächst 55.
Ich bin am 15.03.1975 geboren.
15.03.1975.
Okay.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich wiege 82, 83 kg.
Ich bin ein bisschen mehr, ein bisschen weniger.
Ich bin 1,75 m.
Wo wohnen Sie, Herr Bergmann?
Ich wohne natürlich in Lörrach.
Könnten Sie mir den Namen Ihres Hauchlars verraten?
Ja, Dr. Sacher.
Vielen Dank für die Informations-
Ja, N-I-E.
H-O-F-F.
Herr, wie alt sind Sie und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 57 Jahre alt.
Und bin geboren am 20. August 1968.
68.
Ja.
Wie schwer und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich wiege 88 kg und bin 1,82 m groß.
82.
Groß. Wichtig?
Ja.
Frau Lehmann, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 32 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 13. März, 82.
82.
Nein, 92.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,63 m.
Und wie viel Wegen sind Sie?
Ungefähr 65 kg.
65 kg.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 42 Jahre alt.
Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin geboren am 3. April, 1900.
74.
73.
Nein, 83.
83.
Okay.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Römmel?
Ich bin 1,82 m.
83.
Und wie viel Wegen sind Sie?
85 kg.
Okay, schön.
Was ist dir Hausast?
Das ist der Herr Krakow.
Der ist in der Schulstraße.
Okay, schön.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 78 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin geboren am 23. März, 1900.
Was ist das?
47.
47 Jahre alt.
Und wie groß sind Sie, Herr Leiter?
1,79 m.
Und wie viel Wegen sind Sie?
Circa 82 kg.